from a gravy pizza to a pint of frosting
we wanted to find out all the
differences between seasonal fast food
menus in the uk and the us
this is food wars
let's start with mcdonald's now they've
gone quite big and added five
seasonal items to that menu mcdonald's
in the us only has two menu items and
actually one of them
isn't very festive this thing is itching
me and making a lot of noise i'm taking
it off
santa claus you got it in the u.s
mcdonald's has the holiday pie
and the mcrib now let's start with what
for me is probably the main event which
is this
the double big mac now i have a couple
of reservations about this burger
number one i'm not sure what makes it
christmassy and number two
i'm not sure you can really call it a
double big mac unless it is actually
double the weight and size of a regular
big mac
i mean it is kind of tall
about 275
so it's actually only a 30 increase if
you get the double big mac
which as i suspected is far from
doubling it harry i feel you on that
double big mac so
i'm gonna make one of my own and see
exactly what you're working with over
there
one piece of bread in the middle the
middle piece of bread is always really
strange
i mean this is looking this is actually
looking pretty good right let's see how
much it weighs
280 grams mcdonald's i'm a bit
disappointed because you've advertised
this as a double big mac but you've only
given us 30
more so what we're gonna do now is make
our own double big mac the official way
whoa it's a bit messy
now the other seasonal sandwich item on
the mcdonald's menu is this the jerk
chicken sandwich
now in this burger you'll find two
chicken strips some bacon
some cheese some lettuce some onions and
a spicy jerk sauce next up we have these
things which are cheese melt dippers
these come in portions of
4 or as a share box of 12 and it's
basically like a breaded and fried bite
of camembert cheese
on the dessert menu we have a
celebrations mcflurry
which is a nod to britain's obsession
with chocolate selection boxes around
christmas time
now celebrations is mars addition to
this and what they have
in here is galaxy twix
mars snickers and maltesers
of those candy bars you mentioned i've
heard of two of them one of them was
twix
but besides that i'm not familiar with a
lot of those candy bars so maybe we
should do a food wars candy bars episode
finally mcdonald's offers a salted
caramel latte one thing to note is that
the anti-caking agent used in the
caramel sugar for this latte
is calcium silicate now this is fairly
commonly used in food however it's also
one of the most popular fire proofing
materials
and is also used to neutralize acids
that leak out of mines
the mcrib i have no idea why the mcrib
is during this holiday season at
mcdonald's i think what they do with the
mcrib is they pretty much liquefy the
meat then pour it into a rib shape
mold
oh yeah oh yeah
kfc in the uk only has one exclusive
seasonal menu item and it is this
this is the gravy burger box meal this
is a combo meal in which you get a
regular portion of fries
a single chicken fillet some gravy gravy
nays
which is a new addition to the menu
which is a kind of gravy and mayo
combination and then the main event is
the burger so what they've done here is
taken a philip burger put some cheese on
it
and then on top of it it's got a hash
brown they've kind of put like a divot
in it
and the idea is that you pour the gravy
straight on there and it kind of
collects it in a pool
in this there are 1215 calories
which is quite a lot and i'm not sure
how this is the case but this is
actually more calories
than a 14 piece bargain bucket i love
that reservoir that's such a good idea
that innovation is that only in the uk
that's fantastic
here in the us our kfc actually doesn't
have any exclusive menu items
we do however have this an exclusive
kfc festive bull my boy colonel's
wearing a hat similar to mine
uh what else is on here curse of font
that's holiday got the uh
ornament but that's it oh wait i almost
forgot
look at this thing you know what this is
do you guys know what this is look at
this
so this yule log smells like this
lame ass bucket out of my way this
smells
exactly like kfc fried chicken do you
put a fight with the paper how does this
work
nah it doesn't i think the burning of it
is is crucial for it
doesn't smell like oh hang on
yeah it doesn't okay so it doesn't smell
like fried chicken now
but i'm gonna take this home i'm gonna
throw it on my grill i'm gonna light it
up my whole neighborhood is gonna smell
like fried chicken
thanks to me that's gonna be my holiday
gift to my neighborhood
the gift of things smelling like things
now if there's one chain you can count
on to go all out for the holidays it's
starbucks
let's take a look at some of their
exclusive menu items starting with
the drinks now starbucks uk has added
four drinks to its seasonal menu and
we'll start on this side
this is a truffle deluxe hot chocolate
this is a gingerbread latte which is
festive for
obvious reasons this is an eggnog latte
now i've never actually
tried eggnog and then finally we have a
toffee latte
again not hugely sure how this is
festive but i like toffee i like nuts
sounds like my kind of drink
[Music]
see the thing about eggnog is every year
i look
forward to the holiday season when i
finally get my hands on some nog
and then like clockwork i have like a
couple sips and then i realized why i
didn't think of eggnog for the past 11
months
and i feel like this year will be no
different
i'm a nog head i love eggnog
and two sips is all i can handle pour
the rest of that in the toilet
these are the four exclusive starbucks
holiday drinks that we did get our hands
on they didn't label them so
i'm gonna find out in real time what
they are it's like smelling the cork
just i pretty sure this is the toasted
hot chocolate it's just okay
this is the ooh they labeled it the
peppermint mocha frappuccino
oh it's got bits of stuff in it
ugh toothpastey that's what it tastes
like
when you know you brush your teeth and
then you drink a milkshake that's
exactly what it tastes like
this last one oh god i know which one
this one is
this is a caramel brule latte
the caramel stuff at starbucks is all
terrible
nope this is no different
now we love christmas sandwiches in the
uk a lot of like the supermarket chains
will bring them out around christmas
time
and starbucks is getting in on the act
with quite a few of its own offerings
let's start with this one this is the
tis the season turkey sandwich this is
the very merry
vegan wrap i love the festive colors
they've got going on here great addition
now this one might provoke some
philosophical questions as to what
constitutes a sandwich
but this is the celebration salmon and
cream cheese croissant
this is the turkey festive feast panini
all the good stuff
no vegetables fantastic now the one i'm
probably most excited to try
is this one it's the one with the gravy
layer sandwich now if you're a fan of
the show
friends you might recognize this as a
moist maker
as you can probably tell by the
difficulty i'm having swallowing this
goddess i'm a little disappointed the
whole point of the french sandwich is
that it had a gravy layer in the middle
that made it super moist they've not
really done that with this one it's just
three layers of bread the ratios are all
off
over here is a cranberry bliss bar
you can get a whole tray of the
cranberry bliss bar
the toasted ham and swiss
sandwich and of course egg this handsome
gentleman right here you got yourself a
snowman shaped cookie it's frosty
and if you want just the head
booyah a decapitated
frosty head and a stick sending a
message to the rest of the snowman
stay in line stay in line salted
peppermint bark
right yeah classic people seem to like
these and then to round out the
christmas menu from starbucks we have a
bunch of festive baked goods
we'll start on this side with a
cranberry cheesecake muffin
bad pun come on guys now i'm not sure if
mince pies are a thing
outside of the uk or at least to the
degree they are inside the uk
but basically it's made with mince meat
which is not as bad as it sounds it's
like
baked fruits that kind of stewed a bit
we have this adorable little guy
who's called south pole sam i love him
he is my son
sea salted caramel swirl which i don't
know when salted caramel became festive
then we have this guy the christmas tree
brownie
and then finally we have this thing
which is a raspberry and pistachio
linzer cookie it looks like a fancy
jammy dodger
i want to take this brief moment to talk
about that snowman head cake pop you saw
only a moment ago now i know that little
guy is cute you want to snack on it this
holiday season
i would be remissed if i didn't share
with you the ingredients list
okay ingredients the cake which is sugar
enriched wheat flour
which is wheat flour malted barley flour
niacin
reduce iron thiamine mono nitrates
riboflavin folic acid
diglycerides polysorbite 660
citric acid b h t antioxidant can we
bookmark that one thank you
maltodextrin and natto color extract and
potassium hydrates
you know the one ingredient that i
bookmarked five minutes ago bht
that is butylated hydrotulane
i think that's how it's pronounced i'm
pretty sure that's how that's pronounced
if i've never had to say
it's beautiful hydro delactulosalin
studies have suggested that bht along
with similar chemical
bha increase the risk of cancer in
animals
woof so even though that cake pop
there's a little frosted snowman head on
it
looks cute and fun and your kids want to
have it you'd be better off skipping the
cake pop and just feeding them the stick
now let's look at some of the best of
the rest starting with pizza hut
what pizzas have done is take some
classic uk christmas dinner ingredients
and put them onto a pizza
so we've gone for the classic base and
then on top of that we have a red wine
gravy
instead of pizza sauce we have some
cheese
some bacon some stuffing and some
rotisserie chicken the red wine base
does actually contain alcohol so there
is some real red wine in there
i'm not sure how many of these you'd
have to eat to get drunk i think the
grease would probably kill you before
alcohol poisoning did
i don't know what it is about that pizza
but it's incredibly depressing something
about
all the things that should be at this
full family
christmas feast all in one pizza let's
be honest for some guy by himself
it's a bummer i imagine a guy eating
that pizza
alone in his apartment one light bulb
just swinging above his head
just like staring out into the distance
just
no one in his life and i i don't know
why i'm projecting such sadness on this
pizza but
that is a very depressing pizza
chick-fil-a in the u.s has two exclusive
holiday menu items
a soup their chicken tortilla soup and a
shake
a peppermint chip shake um at first
glance
kind of yuck smells alright
and it comes with these uh crispy
seasonal tortilla strips
all right i'll try it for you guys
happy holidays
surprisingly not bad that's not bad at
all
burger king in the uk is getting
involved with their own addition which
is the festive bbq king
however we have a problem now the one
thing that was supposed to make this
burger festive is the fact that it
contains 5 onion rings which symbolize
five gold rings from the christmas song
however when ours arrived
what did we find we found one two
three and maybe a half onion rings
that is not the song burger king this is
no longer a festive burger
you've failed dunkin donuts in the us
does have
quite a few promotional products four
seasonal drinks
seasonal sandwich and these very fun
and seasonal donuts check those out what
the fun those are for breakfast
sandwiches dunkin donuts has this
their sourdough breakfast sandwich and
just as
advertised two big pieces of sourdough
bread
got eggs bacon cheese
at the size of this thing
yeah i do so we have the signature
peppermint mocha latte this is
the sugarplum i think macchiato
the chai latte with oat milk don't know
why that's so seasonal
and the gingerbread latte
woof oh my god that tastes like cough
syrup
no dunkin donuts no to this get that off
of your menu
immediately there
like i said there's three drinks
now i know i have never seen or heard of
a sugar plum
irl till today because if that's what
they taste like
you stain a dickens carol
you